let's do some examples simplifying
trigonometric expressions so let's say
that I have 1 minus sine squared theta
and this whole thing times cosine cosine
squared theta so how could I simplify
this well the one thing that we do know
this is the most fundamental trig
identity this comes straight out of the
unit circle is that cosine squared theta
plus sine squared theta is equal to 1
and then if we subtract sine squared
theta from both sides we get cosine
squared theta is equal to 1 minus sine
squared theta so we have two options we
could either replace this 1 minus sine
squared theta with the cosine squared
theta or we could replace this cosine
squared theta with the 1 minus sine
squared theta well I'd prefer to do the
former because this is a more
complicated expression so if I can
replace this if I can replace this with
a cosine squared theta then I think I'm
simplifying this so let's see this will
be cosine squared theta times another
cosine squared theta and so all of this
is going to simplify to this is cosine
theta times cosine theta times cosine
theta times cosine theta well that's
just going to be cosine to the fourth of
theta let's do another example let's say
let's say that we have let's say that we
have sine squared theta sine squared
theta all of that over all of that over
1 minus sine squared theta what is this
going to be equal to well we already
know that 1 minus sine squared theta is
the same thing as cosine squared theta
so it's going to be sine squared theta
over over this thing is the same thing
as cosine squared theta we just saw that
over cosine squared theta which is going
to be equal to you could view this as
sine theta over cosine theta whole
quantity squared but what's sine over
cosine that's tangent so this is equal
to tangent squared theta let's do one
more example
let's say that we had let's say that we
have cosine squared theta plus 1 minus
plus 1 minus I so let's make it this way
plus 1 plus sine squared theta sine
squared theta what is this going to be
well you might be tempted especially
with way I wrote the colors to think hey
is there some identity for 1 plus sine
squared theta this is really all about
rearranging it to realize that G I by
the unit circle definition I know what
cosine squared theta plus sine squared
theta is cosine squared theta plus sine
squared theta for any given theta is
going to be equal to 1 so this is going
to be equal to 1 plus this one right
over here plus this one over here which
is equal to 2